sausage stands are a common sight in
Copenhagen it doesn't take much to set
one up you need a grill some sausages
and of course a mobile credit card
payment device these days only tourists
use cash in the end when we have to
count the register thus less money to
count it's a bit easier this again less
room to make errorless less things to
have too far so for me and the other
guys to have in our head when we were
closing down after a long day 20 years
ago Danes paid for 80% of their
purchases in cash now it's less than 25
percent I never have cash actually I
said it's almost a problem when you know
then people go around from those who do
all collect some money for good reasons
I never have cash to put in the box
because we don't use fashion
survelliance and the people that they
their lives gets transparent it's not
just Danish consumers who prefer to pay
with plastic retailers are in the
forefront of the move to abolish cash
drugstore chain Matta's now allows
cellphone payments in all its stores
scan the barcode confirm the payment and
it's done it's faster than standing in
line for the cash register we are
interested in getting rid of the cash
it's the handling the security and
everything around it is very expensive
so definitely want to push that and
that's us of course also why we
introduced the mobile payment to help
this process Danish businesses which
don't sell food may soon be getting
permission to stop taking cash entirely
but politicians and central bank
officials have not yet fixed a date for
that to happen
we are obliged to supply the amount of
cash the population and the companies
demand and we do that but on the other
side we think it's also important that
we have an efficient secure payments
infrastructure this whole process of
reducing the costs of payments I think
the whole digitalization that's very
important in a country like Denmark the
sausage stand may be the next to accept
cellphone payments a third of all Danes
already use an app that makes it
possible even the coffee vendor next
door has already decided to accept
digital payments after all there's
barely room in his tiny truck to store
cash